okay we're on problem number 16 see it
drew us something here that's the point
from point A to point B I have a line
and i have another from b to c then I
have another from here to here okay so
what are they telling us they tell us
this is a 90 degree angle oh whoops not
what I wanted to do and it undo using
the wrong tool so tell us this is a 90
degree angle this is a 90 degree angle
this is a this is B this is C this is D
and they say the figure above shows the
route of Diane's trip from our house to
her job Diane travels 16 miles from A to
B so this is 16 15 miles from B to C so
this is 15 and 4 miles from C to D so
this is for if she would have travel
from A to D directly how much shorter
miles of the trip be so what it would be
the direct route i'm assuming they're
kind of talking you know if she could
fly what would her be a direct route so
that would be this route oh i was
thought i was using the line tool and it
undo i'll do it in a better color anyway
so use the line tool so this is the
direct route right here this is why we
want to figure out the distance of this
so how can we figure out the distance
this and the trick here is to just read
is to realize that this is going to be
the hypotenuse of a right triangle and
you might mean seem confusing you know
your initial impulse might happen to you
know say this is X and this is 15 minus
X and all of this fancy stuff or or what
you could do is you could say well this
side here we know what this is this
length whoops maybe draw it a little bit
better
that length what's that length well this
length is going to be the same as this
length right if we assume this is a
90-degree angle it's going to be 15 and
then what's this length right here
what's this length right here what's
going to be the same as this length up
here right I just kind of extended a
rectangle so this length right here is
four so what is what is this entire
length it's going to be 16 plus 4 so
it's 20 so now this that my what we're
trying to figure out her straight line
distance is nothing but the hypotenuse
of a rectangle of a right triangle where
we know the other two sides so we can
say if this is her straight line
distance X we could say x squared is
equal to 20 squared 20 squared plus 15
squared or x squared is equal to C this
is 400 plus 225 is equal to 6 25 and the
square root of 625 is 25 so X is equal
to 25 so her straight line distance is
25 and how far was she traveling before
let's see she was going 16 16 plus 15
plus 15 plus 4 so that's 20 she was
going 35 what is that miles right miles
she was going 35 miles and if she goes
straight she goes 25 miles so she would
save 10 miles if she went straight if
she was able to fly so that's choice C
next problem
problem number 17 problem 17 one circle
has a radius of one half and another
circle has a radius of 1 what is the
ratio of the area of the larger circle
to the area of the smaller circle let's
see so area the area of circle one area
one is going to be equal to what it has
a radius of one half right so it's PI R
squared is the radius so it's PI one
half squared and what's the area of
circle to the area of circle to is has
rated so an area of circle to its pi
times its radius and its radius is 1 so
2 1 squared so the ratio of the area of
the larger circle to the smaller circle
which one's going to have the lot which
is going to be the larger circle this
one is because it has a larger radius
right as a radius of 1 so the ratio of
the larger circle to the smaller circle
and that's might be where you messed up
if you flip the to the ratio of the
larger circle to the smaller circle is
equal to PI times one right well that's
just pi over pi times one half squared
one-half squared the PI's cancel out so
we have it equals one over one-fourth or
what we could do is we could multiply
the numerator the denominator by 4 which
equals 4 over 1 so the ratio is four to
one and that's choice D problem 18 image
clear image problem 18 if the sum of the
consecutive integers from minus 22 2x
inclusive is 72 what is the value of x
so this is a number that we've actually
done a problem very very similar to this
so it shows you that people in the s80
they think of a lot of creative problems
but every now and then
they have to repeat so they're saying
the sum of the consecutive integers from
minus 22 2 X is 72 so let's think about
this let's draw the sum so it's you know
it's minus 22-22 plus minus 21 plus
minus 20 right plus it keeps going until
it gets to you know 0 plus 0 and then
and I'm going to and then I'm going to
go this way again I'm doing that for
reason and then you can j plus 1 plus 2
plus and you keep going and then you
have + + 20 + 21 + 22 + 23 + 24 all the
way until we get 2x right what you need
to realize what you need to realize is
all the way from minus 20 22 22 the sum
is 0 and why is that well look at the
way I drew it so minus 22 we're taking
the sum of everything right so minus 22
is going to cancel out with positive 22
you add those together yet 0-21 is going
to cancel out with positive 21-20 is
going to cancel out with positive 20 and
so forth and so on so everything so the
sum from minus 22 plus member bobfm all
the way to plus 22 that equals 0 right
so the only we only get into the
positive sum once we get to 23 right so
23 plus 24 plus you know some something
something something is X right and we
have to get to 72 72 and here we can
just eyeball it 23 plus 24 plus 25
what's that well their average 24 24 x 3
72 or we could just add it up let c 23
plus 24 is 47 47 plus 25 equals 72 so
the last number that we use in this
whole range is 25 so this is X that is X
and all we did is we said think about it
take the sum from minus 22 all the way
to positive 25 everything up to negative
22 from minus 22 the positive 22 all of
those cancel out with each other so the
sum is just going to be 23 plus 24 plus
25 that equals 72 so then X is 25 next
problem i'm running out of time so i
better do it in the next video see you
soon